الباطل تكتمون
كتابه
[Silence]
‏pretty much
جزاك الله خير
[Silence]
السلام عليكم
جميل
السلام
[Silence]
‏We be stting back now insall
if I brought my three kids here and run
around the whole time we were making and
screaming. ‏Would you guys appreciate
that as the imam? No. Whatever applies
to me applies to you, applies to
everyone. We have babysitters
or they need to be in bed, one or the
other. We give an option. So we have the
right to say, "Hey, please get your kids
under control." So this is the first
day. And for the kids that are old
enough to listen,
this is not a playground. ‏This is a big
giant beautiful right there. You could
run around it as much as you want. Not
in here. This is for
ahad and start.
اوك
[Silence]
استووا واعتدلوا
لاين
جابس
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
زين للناس حب الشهوات من النساء
والبنين والقناطير المقنطره من الذهب
والفضه والخيل المسومه والانعام والحرف
ذلك متاع الحياه الدنيا والله عنده حسن
قل اانبئكم بخير من ذلكم للذين اتقوا عند
ربهم جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
وازواج مطهره
ورضوان من
والله بصير بالعباد
الذين يقولون ربنا ربنا اننا امنا فاغفر
لنا ذنوبنا وقنا عذاب النار
الصابرين والصادقين والقانتين والمنفقين
والمستغفرين
بالاسحار
شهد الله انه لا اله الا هو والملائكه
واولو العلم قائما
بالقسط
لا اله الا هو العزيز الحكيم
ان الدين عند الله الاسلام
وما اختلف الذين اوتوا الكتاب الا من بعد
ما جاءهم
العلم بغيا بينهم
ومن يكفر بايات الله فان الله سريع الحساب
فان حاجوك
فقل اسلمت وجهي لله ومن اتبعا
وقل للذين اوتوا الكتاب والاميين
اسلمتم
فان اسلموا فقد اهتدوا وان تولوا فانما
عليك البلاغ
والله بصير بالعباد
ان الذين يكفرون بايات الله
ويقتلون النبيين بغير حق ويقتلون الذين
يامرون بالقسط من الناس فبشرهم
فبشرهم بعذاب اليم
اولئك
الذين حبطت اعمالهم في الدنيا والاخره وما
للناصرين
الم تر الى الذين اوتوا نصيبا من الكتاب
يدعون الى كتاب الله ليحكم بينهم ثم يتولى
فريق منهم وهم معرضون
ذلك بانهم قالوا لن تمسنا النار الا اياما
معدودات
وغره في دينهم ما كانوا يفترون
فكيف اذا جمعناهم ليوم لا ريب فيه
ووفيت كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا يظلمون
قل اللهم مالك الملك تؤتي الملك من تشاء
وتنزع الملك ممن تشاء
وتعز من تشاء
وتذل من تشاء
بيدك الخير
انك على كل شيء قدير
تولج الليل في النهار وتولج النهار في
الليل وتخرج الحي من الميت وتخرج الميت من
الحي
وترزق من يشاء بغير حساب
لا يتخذ المؤمنون الكافرين اولياء من دون
المؤمنين
ومن يفعل ذلك فليس من الله في شيء الا ان
تتقوا منهم تقاه
ويحذركم الله نفسه والى الله المصير
قل ان تخفوا ما في صدوركم او تبدوه يعلمه
الله
ويعلم ما في السماوات وما في الارض والله
على كل شيء قدير
يوم تجد كل نفس ما عملت من خير محضرا
وما عملت من سوء
تود لو ان بينها وبينه
دا بعيدا
ويحذركم الله نفسه والله رؤوف بالعباد
قل ان كنتم تحبون الله فاتبعوني يحببكم
الله ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
والله غفور رحيم
قل اطيعوا الله والرسول
فان تولوا فان الله لا يحب الكافرين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله اصطفى ادم ونوحا وال ابراهيم وال
عمران على العالمين
ذريه بعضها من بعض والله سميع عليم اذ
قالت امراه عمران رب اني نذرت لك ما في
بطني محررا فتقبل مني انك انت السميع
العليم
فلما وضعتها قالت رب اني وضعتها انثى
والله اعلم بما وضعت وليس الذكر كالانثى
واني سميتها مريم واني اعيذها بك وذريتها
من الشيطان الرجيم
فتقبلها ربها بقبول حسن
وانبتها نباتا حسنا وكفلها زكريا
كلما دخل عليها زكريا المحراب وجد عندها
رزقا قال يا مريم انا لك هذا قالت هو من
عند الله
ان الله يرزق من يشاء بغير حساب
هنالك دعا زكريا يا رب
قال رب هب لي من لدنك ذريه
طيبه انك سميع الدعاء
فنادته الملائكه
وهو قائم يصلي في المحراب ان الله يبشرك
بيحيى
ان الله يبشرك بيحيى مصدقا بكلمه من الله
وسيدا وحصورا
ونبيا من الصالحين
قال ربي انا يكون قال ربي انا يكون
لي غلام وقد بلغني الكبر وامراتي
عاقب قال كذلك الله يفعل ما يشاء
قال رب اجعل لي ايه قال ايتك الا تكلم
الناس ثلاثه ايام الا رمزا
واذكر ربك كثيرا وسبح بالعشي والابكار
واذ قالت الملائكه يا مريم ان الله اصطفاك
وطهرك واصطفاك على نساء العالمين
يا مريم قلتي لربك واسجدي واركعي
مع الراكعين
ذلك من انداء
الغيب بنوحيه اليك وما كنت لديهم اذ يلقون
اقلامهم ايهم يكفل مريم وما كنت لديهم اذ
يختصمون
اذ قالت الملائكه
يا مريم ان الله يبشرك بكلمه منه اسمه
المسيح عيسى ابن مريم وجيها في الدنيا
والاخره ومن مقربين
ويكلم الناس في المهد وكهلا ومن الصالحين
قالت ربنا يكون لي ولد ولم يمسسني بشر قال
ك قال قال كذلك الله يخلق ما يشاء
اذا قضى امرا فانما يقول له كن فيكون
ويعلم
الكتاب والحكمه والتوراه
والانجيل
ورسولا الى بني اسرائيل
انني قد جئتكم بايه من ربكم
اني اخلق لكم من الطين كهيئه الطير فانفخ
فيه فيكون طيرا باذن الله
وابرئ الاكمه والابرص واحيي الموتى باذن
الله
وانبئكم بما تاكلون وما تدخرون في بيوتكم
ان في ذلك لايه لكم ان كنتم مؤمنين
ومصدقا لما بين يدي من التوراه ولاحل لكم
بعض الذي حرم عليكم وجئتكم بايه من ربكم
فاتقوا الله واطيعون
ان الله ربي وربكم فاعبدوه
هذا صراط
مستقيم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله برب
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال الين
امين
ان الله ربي وربكم فاعبدوه هذا صراط
مستقيم
فلما احس عيسى منهم الكفر قال من انصاري
الى الله قال الحواريون نحن انصار الله
امنا لله واشهد بانا مسلمون
ربنا امنا بما انزلت واتبعنا
الرسول فاكتبنا مع الشاهدين
ومكروا ومكر الله والله خير الكرين
اذ قال الله يا عيسى اني متوفيك ورافعك
الي ومطهرك من الذين كفروا
وجاعل الذين اتبعوا دعوك فوق الذين كفروا
الى يوم القيامه ثم الي مرجعكم فاحكم
بينكم فيما كنتم فيه تختلفون
فاما الذين كفروا فاعذبهم عذابا شديدا في
الدنيا والاخره وما لهم من ناصرين
واما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فيوفيهم
اجورهم
والله لا يحب الظالمين
ذلك نتلوه عليك من الايات والذكر الحكيم
ان مثل عيسى عند الله كمثل ادم خلقه من
تراب ثم قال له كن فيكون
الحق من ربك فلا تكن من الممترين
فمن حاجك
فيه من بعد ما جاءك من العلم فقل تعالوا
ندع ابناء
وابناءكم
ونساءنا
ونساءكم
وانفسنا
وانفسكم
ثم نبتهل
ثم نبتهل فنجعل نعمه الله على الكاذبين
ان هذا لهو القصص الحق وما من اله الا
الله
وان الله لهو العزيز الحكيم
فان تولوا فان الله عليم
بالمفسدين
قل يا اهل الكتاب تعالوا الى كلمه سواء
بيننا وبينكم
الا نعبد الا الله ولا نشرك به شيئا
ولا يتخذ بعضنا بعضا اربابا من دون الله
فان تولوا فقولوا اشهدوا بانا مسلمون
يا اهل الكتاب لم تحاجون
في ابراهيم وما انزلت التوراه والانجيل
الا من بعده افلا تعقلون
ها انتم هؤلاء
حاجتم فيما لكم به علم فلم
تحاجون
فيما ليس لكم به علم والله يعلم
وانتم لا تعلمون
ما كان ابراهيم يهوديا ولا نصراني
ولكن كان حنيفا مسلما وما كان من المشركين
ان اول الناس بابراهيم للذين اتبعوه وهذا
النبي والذين امنوا والله ولي المؤمنين
ودت طائفه
من اهل الكتاب لو يضلونكم وما يضلون الا
انفسهم وما يشعرون
يا اهل الكتاب لم تكفرون بايات الله وانتم
تشهدون
يا اهل الكتاب لم تلبسون الحق بالباطل
وتكتمون الحق وانتم تعلمون
وقالت طائفه
من اهل الكتاب امنوا بالذي انزل على الذين
امنوا وجه النهار واكفروا اخره لعلهم
يرجعون
ولا تؤمنوا الا لمن تبع دينكم
قل ان الهدى هدى الله ان يؤتى احد مثل ما
اوتيتم او يحاجوكم
عند ربكم قل ان الفضل بيد الله يؤتيه من
يشاء
والله واسع عليم
يختص برحمته من يش شاء
والله ذو الفضل العظيم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ومن اهل الكتاب من ان تامنه بقنطا
يؤده اليك ومنهم من ان تامنه بدينار لا
يؤده اليك الا ما دمت عليه قائما
ذلك بانهم قالوا ليس علينا في الاميين
سبيل ويقولون على الله الكذب وهم
يعلمون
بلى من اوفى بعهده واتقى فان الله يحب
المتق قين
ان الذين يشترون بعهد الله وايمانهم ثمنا
قليلا اولئك لا خلاق لهم في الاخره
ولا يكلمهم الله ولا ينظر اليهم يوم
القيامه ولا يزكيهم ولهم عذاب اليم
وان منهم لفريق قا يلوون السنتهم بالكتاب
لتحسبوه من الكتاب وما هو من الكتاب
ويقولون هو من عند الله وما هو من عند
الله ويقولون على الله الكذب وهم يعلمون
ما كان لبشر ان يؤتيه الله الكتاب والحكم
والنبوه ثم يقول للناس الناس كونوا
عبادا لي من دون الله
ولكن كونوا ربين بما كنتم تعلمون الكتاب
وبما كنتم تدرسون
ولا يامركم ان تتخذوا الملائكه
والنبيين اربابا
ايامكم بالكفر بعد اذ انتم مسلمون
واذ اخذ الله ميثاق النبيين لما اتيتكم من
كتاب وحكمه ثم جاءكم رسول مصدق لما معكم
لتؤمنن به ولتنصرنه
قال ااقررتم واخذتم على ذلكم اصري قالوا
اقررنا قال فاشهدوا انا معكم من الشاهدين
فمن تولى بعد ذلك فاولئك هم الفاسقون
افغير دين الله يبغون
افغير دين الله يبغون وله اسلم من في
السماوات والارض طوعا وكرها واليه يرجعون
قل امنا بالله وما انزل علينا وما انزل
على ابراهيم واسماعيل واسحاق ويعقوب
والاسباط وما اوتي موسى وعيسى والنبيون
من ربهم
لا نفرق بين احد منهم ونحن له مسلمون
ومن يبتغي غير الاسلام دينا فلن يقبل منه
وهو في الاخره من الخاسرين
كيف يهدي الله قوما كفروا بعد ايمانهم
وشهدوا ان الرسول حق وجاءهم
البينات
والله لا يهدي القوم الظالمين
اولئك جزاؤهم
ان عليهم لعنه الله والملائكه
والناس اجمعين
خالدين فيها لا يخفف عنهم العذاب ولا هم
ينظرون
الا الذين تابوا من بعد ذلك واصلحوا فان
الله غفور رحيم
ان الذين كفروا بعد ايمانهم ثم ازدادوا
كفرا لن تقبل توبتهم واولئك
هم الضالون
ان الذين كفروا وماتوا وهم كفار فلن يقبل
من احدهم ملء الارض ذهبا ولو افتدى به
اولئك لهم عذاب اليم وما لهم من ناصرين
لن تنالوا البر حتى تنفقوا مما تحبون
وما تنفقوا من شيء فان الله به عليم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
ورحمه الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سووا واعتدلوا
ركعه
ركعه وتر ان شاء الله
الله
اكبر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قل اعوذ برب الفلق
من شر ما خلق
ومن شر غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر النفاثات
في العقد ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن من حمده
الله
اكبر
سبحان الله
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم قل اعوذ برب رب
الناس
قل اعوذ برب الناس ملك الناس اله الناس
من شر الوسواس الخناس
الذي يوسوس في صدور الناس
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبرلام
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك
ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصا ئب
الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا
وقواتنا
ما احييتنا
واجعله الوارث منا
واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا
وانصرنا
على من عادانا
اللهم اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير
مفتونين
فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم احيينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا
وتوفنا اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم صل
وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
واتباعه
اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
السلام عليكم
worked out